les pieds de goyave y est sagement
alignées contraste avec la nature
luxuriante entourant ce chant à la
plaine des palmistes
le verger du brun noir a été créé en
2005 c'est le travail de georges marie
arginthe et sa femme marie rose sur ce
terrain de 2 hectares le couple s'adonne
à la culture biologique du petit fruit
rouge au bout unique depuis tout jeune
homme mon rêve d'être agriculteur sur
tout le monde surtout ma femme on n'a
jamais voulu d'utiliser les pesticides
insecticides
nous ce qu'on voulait c'est faire
quelque chose de seine c'était un
terrain en friche et un jour ma femme et
moi nous est venue sur place de la
allonge un petit coup de r&d ayant dans
leur regard des nazis bombay qu'est ce
qui pousse bien la peine en fin de
compte en respectant la nature
on a vu les goyaviers il y avait des
cultures qui commençaient à lancer juste
plus bas donc je disais mais pourquoi
pas le guen
la structure particulière de la
plantation est lié à la volonté des
cultivateurs faire une agriculture
contrôler dans le respect de
l'environnement
l'espacement entre les arbres permet
l'entretien du chant tous les goûts y
avait peut être que dit son père
et cela évite aux visiteurs de
s'aventurer dans les fourrés au risque
d'abîmer d'autres espèces végétales
c'est un mode d'agriculture auquel
george marie crois ce qu'on peut vous
faire deschamps il faut que l'aîné les
jeunes qui arrivent
toi tu fais des champs c'est vrai que
des fois il faut composer aussi avec la
nature faut composer notre nature garder
les plantes à des mecs de cela mais il
faut que ce soit entretenu avec beaucoup
d espaces comme ça le verger dont
environ une à deux tonnes de fruits par
semaine sur une saison de quatre mois à
la réunion la production annuelle est
estimée à 300 tonnes
mais c'est encore peu passionné georges
marie tient à faire contre conscience de
la valeur du bois y aviez on a besoin
d'autres shanghai il ya une demande
tellement forte qu'on en a besoin
l'économie de la plaine des palmistes
passera par le goalie wars il passera
par le goyavier aujourd'hui donnez vous
au niveau agricole et afin de développer
ce secteur économique
il faut aussi créer un engouement au
sein de la jeunesse ce jour là janita
mon on stage au bras noirs et à la
cueillette
à 33 ans il était en reconversion totale
et suit une formation en horticulture à
saint benoît il ressent le désir profond
de se lancer dans la culture du goyavier
il ya vraiment un danger économique
dedans et aujourd'hui ben je suis
épanoui je suis vraiment heureux dans ce
que je suis en train de faire parce que
je j'ai ça en moi depuis que je suis
tout petit en fait j'aime vraiment le
contact avec la nature la terre
la forêt c'est vraiment dans mon sens
fait et je ne vois pas faire autre chose
que ça a jusqu'à la fin de ma vie
une grande partie de la récolte d argent
est destiné à la préparation artisanale
de produits transforme tout est fait de
bois au feu de bois et dans une bassine
en cuivre toutes et tous à la maison je
les confitures en pâte en cire au coulis
achard et rogan tout ce qui est possible
de faire avec le goyavier ils le font
selon des recettes hérité de la
tradition est améliorée avec expérience
aujourd'hui ses confitures en rive ne
fait le lavage ne pas s'en laver à la
main et après les passes dans le robot
je dois avoir la démonstration qu'on
n'est pas
[Musique]
ça c'est un travail est rare est qu'il
faut aimer parce que en fin de compte il
mêle pas et travaille c'est une passion
puisque on regarde par leur nez il le
jour ni la date des fois on reste
jusqu'à minuit 1h du matin deux jeunes
matin pour faire pour prendre quelque
chose c'est le moteur madame c'est le
moteur c'est beaucoup de 1900
ces kilos le succès un conservateur si
on mettrait peux-tu pas de conservation
nous sommes et répétées pour éviter
aussi les problèmes de santé des gens
maintenant et ongs à la conservation
parce qu'on veut une cuisson très lente
là pour une confiture n'ont pas jusqu'à
3h30 4 de cuisson l'eau voilà donc on
met les c'est la patience beaucoup
d'amour non quand il faut tout y est
oublié tout y est on est on voit le fond
y accroche comme ça un petit peu comme
celle là c'est ce puits la confiture
encore bien chaude peut être mis son
bocal avec cinq kilos de pulpe
il obtiendra de 26 coups leurs produits
seront ensuite vendus à leur boutique ou
bien sûr et marché à diverses
manifestations et salons
[Musique]
participez à l'écologie transmettre
revaloriser et promouvoir son des
intérêts majeurs autour du goyavier le
conseil départemental seul compétent en
matière agricole oeuvre ce sens afin que
la filière goyavier évolue encore à
l'avenir et porte ses fruits